streaming TV shows together has become
an increasingly common activity for
couples but there are some shows that
can lead to conversations you probably
don't want to have in the interest of
peace harmony and your overall
well-being you definitely want to steer
clear of watching these shows with your
partner the protagonists of Bravo's
imposters are two men and a woman who've
all been victims of a female con artist
who tricked them into falling in love
with her and then disappeared with all
their money as they pursue the woman who
wronged them all they find themselves
conning others along the way but only
those who they believe deserve it
meanwhile their mutual ex-wife is
falling in love for real putting her
next store at risk will you marry me
no this is basically a show about how
nobody can really be trusted and now
just because you're truly in love with
someone doesn't mean their feelings are
as sincere as yours and if you're going
to watch this with your partner you'd
really better know and trust them
otherwise if you end up jokingly asking
you'd never do that to me
right and their eyes shift just a little
you're never going to stop thinking
about it is it really worth it
HBO's divorce is a black comedy in which
Sarah Jessica Parker and Thomas Haden
Church play a middle-aged couple who
split up after he discovers she's had an
affair ultimately there are many other
reasons that you don't belong with each
other but it can still be jarring to
watch a long seemingly steady
relationship disintegrate and leave both
former partners alone in its aftermath
if you're a young couple who haven't
been together for all that long watching
divorce will have less of an impact if
you're old enough on the other hand and
have been together long enough to have
felt just a little bored in your
relationship as all couples sometimes do
this show may lead to questions like
what would you do if we split up
or even worse do you ever think about
getting a divorce no matter how stable
your relationship really is these
conversations are never fun to have
black mirror which began on the BBC and
is now a Netflix original is a sci-fi
anthology series which holds an
incredibly grim perception of humanity
in the future while many episodes don't
specifically deal with relationships
those that do make the whole prospect
seem nothing less than horrifying the
entire history of you is about a man
obsessed with the possibility that his
wife is cheating on him in a world where
people can replay anything they've seen
hang the DJ raises questions about how
much freedom we really have to be who we
want be right back is about how
technology can make it harder to let go
of a partner moreover black mirrors a
show that basically exists to raise
uncomfortable questions whether the
episode has anything to do with romance
sometimes discussing hard-hitting social
topics with the romantic partner can
lead to uncomfortable places maybe just
watch sand Junipero together and forget
the rest of the series ever happened
Walter White of AMC's Breaking Bad might
just be the worst husband in television
history
he doesn't just lie to his wife he lies
to his wife about not being a crystal
meth cook
by the time Skyler white finds out what
Walt is really up to he's already so
addicted to the power of being a
criminal mastermind that he can never
really go back to being a good husband
to her one more time that you did this
for the family not every couple needs to
tell each other everything about their
lives but this show takes secret-keeping
to new and dangerous heights
you'll definitely find yourself
wondering what your partner has going on
that you don't know about and they'll be
wondering the same thing about you if
you are keeping secrets
that's not exactly going to make things
comfortable for you Netflix's glow is
mostly a pretty upbeat show about
women's wrestling at its center however
our two best friends whose relationship
has been terribly damaged perhaps even
irreparable II by a man debbie is
married to mark and they have a baby
together
however mark is having an affair with
Debbie's best friend Ruth
Debbie blames Ruth and Ruth blames
herself but over the course of the first
season it becomes increasingly clear
that mark is the real deal when Debbie
joins Ruth as part of a woman's
wrestling TV show Merck is embarrassed
and unsupportive throughout when Debbie
reveals at the first live show that she
hasn't given up on wrestling after all
marks derision for Debbie's pursuits is
palpable how did you find this
particular subplot is about how you can
be in a serious relationship without
even realizing that your partner is a
terrible person however unless that's a
specific problem in your relationship in
particular who might be worth watching
together anyway no matter how dark its
relationship storylines might be this is
a show that does have a lot of other
cool stuff going on
[Music]